yeah thank you yeah thank you for having
me and thank you for coming to the talk
I know from firsthand experience that
it's hard to attend to many so I
appreciate that you come out so I intend
to talk about streaming which you've
just heard about and also what author
Arthur Merlin which thankfully yesterday
because of heart notes and Henry's
Andy's talks you've heard about too so
there's a lot that I don't need to
really define for you okay let me talk
about a problem that I think you all
know the nearest neighbor search problem
and I'm going to show you in this talk
and algorithm for this problem of a very
unusual sort yeah anyway the problem is
that you have a data set which is a huge
set of points shown in red here from
some metric space M and if you don't
like to think of an abstract metric
space just think of these as points in
Euclidean space of some high dimension
the task is to pre-process this set of
points and produce a data structure
which you will then use to answer
queries so the problem comes in two
phases naturally first there's the
pre-processing phase and then there's a
query phase in the 24 given a query
point Y and you have to find its nearest
neighbor in that data set denoted by an
N of Y comma X the two important
parameters here are the size of the data
structure that you compute and the time
you take to answer the queries and my
interesting twist is going to be that
I'll think of the whole problem in a
streaming setting so the points are
being streamed to you you only have a
small amount of memory sub-linear amount
of memory and therefore your data
structure itself has to be sub linear in
space yeah and I'll ignore this issue
that the time has to be sub linear
minute sort of naturally will follow but
concentrate on the space used by the
data structure now if you know anything
about streaming they should start
setting off alarm bells and you should
think that this cannot be possible can
be possible to do this at all as stated
and indeed here's a quick proof that
it's not possible so nearest neighbor is
a very complicated problem a very very
special case of this problem is when all
the points are in 1d and therefore you
just have a collection of numbers now if
I can solve nearest neighbor then in
particular I should be able to tell you
whether the
even query point actually occurs in the
set of numbers that I saw before so I
have a set of numbers that I see as a
stream I have to reprocess it and
remember something about it so that I
can answer whether any given number
appeared in the stream or not for fairly
simple information theoretic reasons
they should be very hard to do in
particular if you think of this as a
communication game where Alice holds the
data structure Alice holds the data and
therefore will create the data structure
and then will communicate the contents
of this data structure to Bob who will
then answer the query then what I've set
up is really an instance of the famous
index problem which is of course very
hard so any algorithm using three bits
of space gives you a V bit communication
protocol this is not possible unless V
is Omega N and being the say the
universe size and so really there's not
that much you can do so it seems that in
order to solve nearest neighbor as a
data stream problem you need some kind
of help okay all right so that is
believe people know right
well it's author from one of the Monty
Python movies okay so so Arthur Merlin
many of you have seen the concept define
a couple of talks but still I'll give
you my spin on it the general setup is
that you have a computational limit
identity and classically this would mean
that you have a polynomial time
algorithm a randomized polynomial time
algorithm but you want to solve some
problem that you don't believe lies in P
and so you take the help of your wizard
Merlin this the wizard is
computationally arbitrarily powerful and
can solve any problem the only issue is
Arthur doesn't necessarily trust him so
there's a chance that Merlin is trying
to cheat Arthur into accepting an answer
that he accepting some input that he
should not accept I try to find a good
picture of Merlin but all I found was
kind of yes all right okay so anyway
traditionally the these characters are
sometimes also called the verifier and
the prover or helper so we all sometimes
slip into this terminal
now in the streaming setting you can
think of author as modeling a data
stream algorithm so rather than the
limitation being computational time
Arthur's limitation is that he has only
a little amount of memory now how can
Merlin help him well of course Merlin
can help him by not having a limited
amount of memory and therefore being
able to compute anything I want to put
another spin on this thing before going
on with my results which is that I think
in the two tops that we saw yesterday
which involved Arthur and Merlin this
was kind of an intellectual exercise to
understand what the power of Arthur
Merlin model says well actually in
Andy's case he was using it to
understand something else in my case I
want to claim that there is actually
something practical that Merlin can be
seen as modeling so I want to put the
spin that Merlin is a proper model of
what could be a cloud service a
third-party cloud service that you don't
necessarily trust okay so think of this
model of computation you have a
lightweight not very powerful computer
that's doing your data stream processing
so you in the modern age you design some
kind of algorithm which runs partly on
your computer but mostly perhaps on some
server up in the cloud okay so this data
stream is being seen by you as well as
the server up in the cloud for the
server and the cloud the stream is not
really a stream it's just a piece of
data because it doesn't have space
limitations it can do offline processing
but you don't necessarily want to trust
that whatever answer you get from the
cloud is correct so perhaps you want to
engage in a short conversation with the
cloud where the cloud will convince you
that the answer to your problem is
so-and-so and it's correct okay one last
bit of pitching just want to say that
this is a you may say that modeling
cloud as Merlin is perhaps looking too
much because the whole point of Merlin
is that he's untrustworthy
well our cloud services untrustworthy
well you decide I took this out of the
terms of service of a well-known cloud
computing service that I will not name
okay anyway so well that
I took it from their website that's
about as much as I trust very okay fine
let's let's let's get to the
mathematical details so this this is
kind of a theory that I've started
building with quarters especially core
mode and McGregor over a few years and
then there's another important paper by
corpsman mitts and marker and Taylor
which considered interaction between
Arthur and Merlin this set up I can give
you a full history of what was done
before but I won't go into it too much
because I really want to show you this
algorithm okay so the setup is that you
have a stream consisting of M items each
item is from a universe of size n and M
and n are both very huge and I will kind
of think of M and n as being close let's
say polynomial related so I will not
distinguish between them too much you
have an algorithm which has to process
the stream using v bits of memory this
number the letter V is for verification
so I'm using VI rather than s and then
we have this helper Merlin who is also
looking at this stream in parallel and
he has no memory limit and at the end
when the stream is over you transfer
some question about the stream such as
say a nearest neighbor query at this
point Arthur will interact with Merlin
using some communication protocol that
we get to design let H be the number of
bits exchanged in this communication
protocol so we wish the space used here
as well as the communication used here
to be much smaller than M and n sub
linear ideally poly logarithmic and we
want the following semantics if Merlin
is honest and follows the protocol that
we've designed and then Arthur must
output the correct answer with high
probability now on the other hand if
Merlin is dishonest then Arthur must
abort that is to say he must catch
Merlin cheating with very high
probability
so this problem point query which is
simply telling if a given stream
contains a number or not we saw that
this was a very very special case of
nearest neighbor searching and first
going to show you a solution that says
that whereas without Merlin you clearly
require Omega n space for trivial
information theoretic reasons with
Merlin prevalent we can design what we
call a streaming interactive
or a sip with the both parameters around
login and I will show you this algorithm
in some detail and the nearest neighbor
algorithm will follow as a kind of
corollary of this which seems hard to
believe because this problem is a very
very special case of nearest neighbor
nevertheless these contains all the
hardness so yeah so I should note that
you can't hope to go much below the
bound that we have you can probably
shave off the log log and I don't know
how to do it but you need login just to
store one item from the stream okay so
formally the problem is that you're
given these items x1 through XM each in
n set in and the query is some other
potential item Y and you want to know
whether there exists a J with XJ equals
what so does Y appear in the stream now
in the description of the protocol that
is to follow for simplicity assume that
all the items x1 through XM are distinct
I don't really need that but it will
help understand it'll help you
understand the matter better so I will
have a certain set up and on the next
page I will have a lot more formulas
coming up but I'll hopefully walk you
through them and explain everything
we will first use this simple bit of
notation switch where we have a mapping
between integers from 1 up to n 2
strings binary strings namely their
binary representations so I will think
of n as 2 to the B so that every integer
has a B bit representation ok now I will
do all my work on some suitable finite
fields are we going to be doing
arithmetic in this finite field I'll
start off by picking B random elements
in this finite field right now here's
how I process the stream I initialize an
accumulator Q to 0
and each time I read an item in the
stream I update my accumulator in this
manner right now one or two of you may
have figured out what exactly this is
doing if you haven't yet done so don't
worry that I'm going to explain this now
so the net effect of all these additions
is I claim on this you can stare at this
and see this is what's happening you
have evaluated a certain polynomial P at
the point R 1 through R be where the
polynomial is given
this formula and I have really not done
much here I've just changed alright
Rosie died and then written out that
summation it says that's what the
accumulator computes okay now what
exactly is that polynomial hey this is
just a recollection of what we've done
so far
notice that if you plug in zero one
values for that one through that B then
this polynomial is doing something
interesting so first of all it's a sum
of a bunch of terms now let's look at
just one of those terms so the product
inside now let's look at one of the
factors of this product so this X I
these exercise represent binomial so X
super J subscript I so these represent
the bits of the items that appeared in
the stream okay so they're binary
representations of the integers that
appear in the stream most importantly
each xji is either 0 or 1
now if I think of plugging in that
either 0 or 1 then it's easy to check
that this little expression in here
tells you whether X is equal to 0 it's
just a simple equality test therefore
the product tells you whether the tuples
that one through that B is equal to the
tuple of X 1 through X B okay and
therefore in the sum the jth term is a 1
if that is equal to XJ so this is a
tuple equality so this this B 2 blue is
equal to this is beautiful
otherwise it's equal to 0 so it's equal
to 0 if that is not equal to X so all
this works for that being a binary
string of bits okay all right so the net
effect is that the sum then computes the
number of times that a particular item
that appears on the stream yeah now
because I assume that the elements of
the stream are all distinct this count
is really telling you whether the items
are appeared in the stream or not so
this interpretation hopefully makes
sense it's if you plug in boolean values
it tells you presence or absence of the
numbers in the string but now of course
you're free to plug in things that are
not boolean yeah so here's another view
of what we've done so far we had the
data stream which is a collection of
integers this collection of integers is
then mapped to a collection of points in
the boolean hypercube of B dimensions
you can think of the boolean -
were sitting inside this extended
hypercube after the be right for for the
finite we left that we're working on and
the net effect of that entire processing
is to evaluate the polynomial that
represents the stream in some manner at
some random point okay this polynomial
has all the information about the stream
so of course I'm not storing the
polynomial but I'm storing its value at
some particular point right so I've
evaluated the polynomial there in order
to answer a query so a query point is
somewhere in that hypercube I have to
know if the blue query point is sitting
on top of one of the black boxes that
are actually in the stream that's the
same thing as evaluating the same
polynomial P at the query point I have
already evaluated it at that random
point how can I use this information so
here's where Merlin comes into play so I
send Merlin the line through the
evaluation point and the query point
it's a line in the finite field you know
in F to the B it's the finite set of
size exactly order of F so this is my
challenge line and I'm saying my
challenge line to pretending I'm Arthur
okay so suppose I'm Arthur I'm
challenging Merlin tell me the
description of that polynomial P when
restricted to the line yeah so note so
this is coming back to something you've
seen before this is the expression for
the polynomial it is easily seen to be
multi linear in the variables that one
through that B and so if I project it on
a line and its degree will be at most B
right okay so when Arthur sends this
challenge to Merlin Merlin if he is not
cheating should be able to respond with
a degree polynomial univers degree of a
polynomial that represents P on that
line lambda yes yes yes he hides the our
eyes oh good good question so how
exactly does he send he has to describe
this challenge line lambda to Merlin in
a way that doesn't actually reveal the
our eyes so one easy way to do this is
to say that every line is some finite
set order the items in some
lexicographical order and send the first
two so two points uniquely determine the
line that'll do it
and this has no information about our
that's it's a good point
okay Merlin must not know where is the
place that Arthur has evaluated this
polynomial right yeah we will see the
analysis will come up soon anyway so if
Merlin doesn't cheat then Arthur now has
a description of the polynomial as
restricted to that line and we know that
answering the query amounts to
evaluating the polynomial somewhere on
that line so he can go ahead and
evaluate it query is answered okay so
it's done the line is determined by the
point to be queried which Merlin knows
and the evaluation point which Merlin
does not know this was chosen by Arthur
at random okay fine fine fine fine one
other point sure so the method can
method is good for only one query if you
wanted to do multiple queries you have
to store multiple such fingerprints or
what encoding so what have you yeah
given that this is only logarithmic
space it's actually it's okay to do that
all right let's analyze this product
okay I guess some of the analysis has
already started coming out in the
comments so so correctness the protocol
clearly has perfect completeness if
Merlin is honest there's no reason for
any error to happen on the other hand if
Merlin is dishonest and sends some kind
of wrong polynomial which is not
actually the restriction of P 2 lambda
then this polynomial being of degree B
will disagree with our polynomial which
is also degree B at all but B points
right all but at most B points okay so
if I forget unlucky then he would have
evaluated the polynomial at one of these
B points of agreement but the
probability of this happening is B
divided by the cardinality of the line
which is V divided by F now you can make
this as small as you want for example by
picking F to be around 1000 times B this
can be made less than 0.1% okay so I
ought to say I realized that I forgot to
write it down on the slide that this
basic setup an idea really is from a
somewhat older paper of
Ron Rose where his motivation was
something else to do with something to
do with quantum computing I believe yeah
okay anyway the other thing to analyze
is the cost of this algorithm what what
are we storing while processing the
stream will be storing these B random
points from the field so the space taken
is B times log of F remember that we set
the field size to be thousand B so this
is just B log B and remember that n was
2 to the B so B is log n so this is just
log in log log n ok thank you ok good
yeah the communication so if you if you
look at the communication then what
Arthur sends is 2 points in F to the B
so that's order B points in the field F
and what Merlin sends back is a degree B
polynomial so that's again B
coefficients in F and so overall it's B
log F again and so it's the same log n
log 1 right ok so hopefully that made
sense and use several ideas that may
have been familiar to you from other
contexts but if we've done something
very interesting which is we've
effectively solved the index problem one
way index problem with one-way
communication but using only log in
space with thanks to this Merlin thing
yeah I guess it's just a summary of
everything that we have said so far ok
but this only solves point query what
about nearest neighbor
all right so how on earth does this have
anything to do with solving nearest
neighbor so here you'll have to imagine
a few steps but I will eventually make
them a little more concrete first of a
discretization assumption I need this to
make the protocol work I'm going to
assume that my points are in well
they're in some dimension D I'm going to
assume that they're coordinates lie
between 1 and n and I'm also going to
assume that my distance function only
gives me multiples of 1 over N to the D
so this n is some kind of granularity
parameter and this is more or less true
for
you know Euclidean distance l1 distance
or so and so forth and if it's not
exactly one over n to the D but
something like one over N squared to the
D then well it's no big deal the results
won't change you can just assume that
there's some factor here in front of the
D it doesn't change anything okay so let
us consider the set B which is all the
distinct balls in this space so all
possible centers and all possible radii
okay that's a finite set because of this
granularity assumption right now when I
read my stream which is a stream of
points in X then this generates I will
imagine in my mind a virtual stream of
balls okay and here's the virtual stream
so every time I read a point X I imagine
that I'm actually seeing all the balls
that contain this point so all the balls
with centers everywhere possible that
contain this point okay so this virtual
stream is huge fine but it's only
virtual so imagine after processing the
virtual stream as if to perform point
queries okay so you can pretend that
author is seeing a stream of balls and
then he's eventually gonna be able to
answer a membership in the stream of
books right now we were given a query
point why we want to find the nearest
neighbor of Y with with respect to given
their data set not the Union it is the
set of balls so each each each input in
the stream leads to an input of millions
of points in the virtual stream the
length of the virtual stream is equal to
some huge number times the length of
your actual string yeah so a also given
a query point author will do this
three-round interaction with Merlyn
so first Merlin will say here is the
claimed nearest neighbor of your point
now after challenges modeling to prove
that this is correct and notice that
what you have to prove is that the claim
point actually appears in the given
stream so the zero radius ball actually
appears in this virtual stream and also
that this is actually the nearest
neighbor so there's nothing closer than
said to why and this can be rewritten
you can just see this a little bit of
thinking that if you take the ball
centered at Z with radius slightly less
than the distance then it must not
appear in this virtual string right now
these are just two-point queries so we
can solve the whole thing in space that
is logarithmic in the length of this
virtual string and thankfully this is
still order D log n ok so that's a small
space solution now you may say that
that's really cheating because it's a
small space solution that uses a
inordinate amount of time so the work
required to actually process a single
point is do actually pretend that you've
seen this whole virtual stream doesn't
use a lot of space but you have to
actually add whatever it is whatever you
must add to your accumulator so many
times right now there is a way out
actually and this way out gets a little
more algebraically complicated so one
should have full details but I'll do an
idea of what to do
the basic thing to observe is that we
created this virtual stream and the
algorithm that I just showed you assume
that assume no form for this virtual
stream right so it's just some random
stream of balls you know trying to
marbet or a stream of balls but in fact
this virtual stream has some internal
structure it arises from some metric
right such as I don't know Euclidean
metric or something importantly any
reasonable metric comes with an
efficient formula for computing it yeah
so I can take this formula and use write
this formula algebraically and then
instead of creating a multi linear
polynomial extension of the stream in my
as in my point Corey thinks the point
where it represents your stream in the
form of this multi linear polynomial
right which I was showing in the picture
here we can instead get a higher degree
extension by using this formula yeah so
a few quick words on how to do that so I
mean don't consider too much and what
the final results are but I won't won't
tell you the idea for constructing this
extension so let's say we have this
formula Phi which takes two inputs a
description of a ball and the
description of a point and tells you
whether the ball contains the point or
not yeah and the case of say Euclidean
metric this four amount of computing a
Euclidean distance between a
Center and a given point and comparing
it to some given radius and see if it's
less than or equal to or not right the
whole thing has a short has a shallow
circuit you can then turn the circuit
into a polynomial by doing this standard
trick which for instance is certainly
used in Shamir's proof of AI P equals P
space and maybe earlier convert and gets
to multiplication or gates to this thing
and you circuit turns into a polynomial
so now our goal is to point query this
vector which has an entry at each ball
and the entry of a entry at a ball is
whether or not the ball can paint a
given point right so this whole sum now
becomes a sum of a bunch of polynomials
this whole polynomial has low degree
because the degree of this polynomial is
related to the depth of the circuit and
the circuit need not have much depth
because the thing that you're computing
is like just sum of squares and then sum
less than or equal to the operation
that's that's that's why I made this
discretization assumption that the
coordinates are integers so the
coordinates are integers then the
computing squares and adding is just the
usual integer multiplication in addition
the only reason why I have to think
about boolean formulas at all by the way
is because of the less than or equal to
operation I have to compare one distance
to another and say what this is this is
less than that
that's not algebraic and this really
requires a boolean circuit everything
else though is just algebraic
computation okay so that's all I wanted
to say about that let me end with that
too okay I guess I have the couple of
minutes that it started late all right
so this connects to communication
complexity the theory of communication
complexity in the usual way which is
that data stream lower bounds come from
communication complexity or lower bounds
usually if you wanted to prove lower
bounds in this model you have to start
thinking about Arthur model in
communication complexity such as the
kind of things that Hartman was talking
about yesterday except that there's a
slightly different twist on the Arthur
Merlin model here now the data streaming
algorithm naturally gives you a one-way
protocol from a list of
okay so the communication between Alice
and Bob will only be one way on the
other hand Merlin gets to interact with
Bob so Bob represents the player who
gets the tail end of the stream so after
you've seen the stream you get to
interact with Merlin with in some
arbitrary fashion okay
so we'd refer to this kind of a thing
this kind of single an online
interactive proof protocols or oh I pee
with the superscript K representing the
number of rounds of communication
between Bob and Merlin
oh I p1 is already an interesting model
because this represents L is sending
something to Bob and Merlin sending
something to Bob and then Bob deciding
whether he likes the input or not right
that's already an interesting model with
some non-trivial results okay which will
not go into today the protocol that I
implicitly showed you for the index
problem in communication is an IP to
protocol because Alice sends a message
to Bob and Bob send the challenge line
to Merlin Merlin sends something back
and then the answer is gives us an or IP
to protocols you can actually ask what
happens as you use more and more rounds
of communication between Bob and Merlin
and something very interesting happens
this I think it's very interesting you
have separations between the classes or
IP one two three and four but no further
and at why before it becomes the same as
ypk for any other constant K and anyhow
so why this happens will take too long
to explain that I can do it offline I
can I can tell you tomorrow the kind of
no no no sorry no I can tell you
tomorrow
get chilly after tomorrow there's
connections with the classical theory of
interactive proofs but there are
subtleties so not every not every
theorem that you knew for classical
interactive proofs such as Goldwater
sips or just goes through as it is okay
so anyway which is why the collapse is
that for and not too for those of you
who know that very well okay so in
conclusion this is the beginnings of a
theory for verifiable or trustworthy
cloud computing strictly speaking I'm
only looking at one aspect of things is
the streaming and limited memory aspect
there's a ton of other aspects you could
think of looking at so okay we solved
nearest neighbor I didn't say it but
there's a whole bunch of other query
problems we can solve we mention of a
few open problems so of course the first
thing is understanding exactly what we
can solve okay so what was it about the
structure of nearest neighbor can be
abstracted enough and say what is the
most general thing we can solve like
this but more importantly the lower
bounds we don't really have very many
lower bounds as the fourth level of this
hierarchy as I noted before it's
surprisingly powerful and contains all
the other levels and it seems to be
ready to do am in communication
complexity which is a famously hard
thing to lower bound so maybe we can't
do that but here's a possibly tractable
question my nearest neighbor protocol
used three rounds of interaction and I
don't know that I can't do it in two I
think I can't do it in two but I don't
see how to prove it so possibly a good
problem to work on thank you
questions the model doesn't care about
it but how efficient is married so there
is one step that's inefficient yes
Merlin yeah that's right right I we
wrote a few things about this in the
paper especially because we work aiming
to solve nearest neighbor and some
interesting model he certainly doesn't
mean he certainly needs normal in
polynomial time that that part is fine
he he needs a lot of space he does need
to accumulate the entire yeah but I
think he's in polynomial time Lisa yeah
in the stream size yes which is not very
good at all you you want to be mere
linear time or something like this
what is that log space Merlin no no I
don't think so because he needs to be
able to extract the coefficients of the
polynomial for that line I'm not too
sure that this can be done in I guess I
suppose so yeah somewhere yes I'm where
he must need more space because he
otherwise he can't help yes all this
problem yeah but more importantly I
don't know if you can do this in
anything close to linear time even it
may require some okay I don't want to
say something off the cuff but I believe
that the time taken by Merlin again
relates to the size of the circuit which
represents the formula for Euclidean
distance unless than we say something
about it in the paper I should really
look at it carefully to see what is that